it's the run-up to Christmas in London's
main shopping district Oxford Street
Regent Street and Carnaby Street are
particularly well decorated this year as
are the windows of the famous luxury
department stores Selfridges and Harrods
drinking and eating together lots of
decorations the Geoffrey Museum of the
home is putting on a show called
Christmas past
it covers English Christmas traditions
from the past 400 years in the 17th
century sweets were made to look like
eggs bacon or stones up until the 19th
century Christmas was celebrated over 12
days at least by those who could afford
it the twelfth day of Christmas the 6th
of January was the highlight then people
ate a very special cake this cake would
have been eaten on the twelfth night and
baked within the cake would have been a
beam and a pea and so whichever kind of
male member of the family got the beam
would have become the Bing King and this
could have been a small child and it was
supposed to be a joke that then that
child would have been the head of the
household and would have could have seen
over and ruled all of the Christmas
festivities and and I also had the peace
oh and if a girl got the P she would've
been in the P queen and it's also kind
of twisting the hierarchy of the house
the Christmas card was invented in the
mid 19th century in England a German
Christmas tradition made it across the
channel around this time too
Christmas trees another german tradition
made it to england much later the
christmas market the winter wonderland
in Hyde Park is the biggest Christmas
market in Britain it's also got far more
attractions than your average German
market there are some 150 stands selling
handicrafts from the region and over a
hundred rides to choose from enough to
make you feel a bit dizzy last year some
2.5 million visitors came to winter
wonderland it's become a must for locals
and tourists alike mark the lysing I
want to see the ice kingdom when it's
250 sculptures the magical ice kingdom
is one of the highlights here but wrap
up warm because it's minus 10 degrees
Celsius in this icy realm 500 tons of
ice were used to make the kingdom
this giant octopus is five meters high
and weighs a whopping 60 tons those who
really like it cold can enjoy a cool
cocktail here at the ice bar and psych
themselves up for an exhilarating ride
on the giant observation wheel which is
an incredible 60 meters high
[Music]